okay so I'm going to talk to you today
about a competition that I helped to run
in 2016 we were emulating in some sense
the machine learning crowd that does a
ton of you know competitions like the
famous cattle competitions within causal
inference and I'll let you know a little
bit you know in the 20 minutes about how
that went what our results were and you
know what we learned from doing that
seriously okay okay okay how do I go
back
all right yeah seriously badass very
points going down by the second okay
causal inference is hard I know that
sounds whiny that's okay I'm kind of
used to it
why is causal inference hard because
unlike so many fields like you know
machine learning often you can have
training data test data you know how
well you're doing by comparing how you
do once you've built a model on your
training data by applying it to the test
data nothing like that exists in causal
inference right we have missing
counterfactuals what we don't know is
the world that we didn't see so unless
you are able to jump between alternate
universes or go back in time it's really
hard to figure out what the truth was
so we had to make all kinds of
adjustments because of that in the
design but in general causal inference
you've got two main sets of choices one
is run a randomized experiment that's
the gold standard that's what you're
supposed to do but there are lots of
situations where ethically logistically
etc you can't do that I don't need to do
because I've got a can you hear me okay
so we randomized experiments great often
can't do them so then what do we do
observational studies so that's that's
the bulk of what people do and what that
literature is about because yes there's
some statistical literature about
randomized experiments but it's just an
easier task right so when we're in the
world of observational studies we don't
have a randomized experiment the whole
name of the game is accounting for your
covariance okay so what does it mean to
account for your covariance well the
biggest problem there is you probably
haven't measured them all right so being
able to say that I've measured all
confounders everything that predicts
both my treatment and my outcome it's
pretty hard to ever say that that
happened right
so we punted on that that is not part of
this competition you know that's that's
something and then it's not a lot of
part of the literature frankly and I'm
happy
to talk to you about have done some work
in that area but that's that's not about
today so instead what we focused on is
the second part was usually what people
do is say let's just control for
everything we can let's measure as much
as we can let's control for as much as
we can that's great
but once you do that it gets harder and
harder to build models that you actually
believe okay okay so sorry the
competition because of that focus on
this part of it the parametric
assumptions okay so how do we build a
model this is for anyone you see me give
a talk you see inside so I apologize but
most of this crowd is is somewhat native
a so hopefully I won't be boring you too
much
here's causal inference in one slide
I've got a bunch of observations that
received a treatment in red I've got a
bunch of observations that did not
receive the treatment in blue the I've
got one confounder in this case so I've
got set up a really simple situation
where there's only one thing that
predicts whether or not I got the
treatment and it also predicts the
outcome okay so that's great and that's
your pretest score and it's on the
x-axis so what do the solid lines are
the true relationship between that
confounder and my outcome which is a
post-test the whole you know don't use
regression to do causal inference
correlation is not causation it's a
little misleading because actually if
you can get that model right you can do
causal inference right you actually if
you know you've got one confounder you
can fit the right model game on you're
doing well the problem is usually more
the first part we don't know we have all
the confounders and then the second part
it can be hard to model so what's the
hard to model piece of it well that's
the fact that here we've got something
that's not going to be fit well saved
with a linear regression this is this is
why we should be beating up on
regression for causal inference right
because it's just not the right model a
lot of the time so here the true
response surfaces as you see are curve
you fit something linear to that it's
not gonna do well in particular it's not
gonna do well here because I don't have
overlap perfect overlap between the two
groups right so you notice the controls
are hanging out down here with low
pretest scores the treated or up here
with higher pretest scores so then the
model just wants to extrapolate into
that area of the covariant space where I
don't have a lot of information so
another way of thinking about that is
that for these controls I don't really
have people who look like them
I don't have empirical counterfactuals
I've got no one over here saying what
would have happened to me if I'd gotten
the treatment and the same for the
treated over on the right hand side I
don't have controls who look like them
who can give me information about what
would have happened had I not gotten the
treatment and that's the whole name of
the game we need evidence on both sides
we need to be able to think for each
person about that alternate universe
right so we're missing the alternate
universe here okay so there's two pieces
here there's this overlap piece and then
there's this fitting curves is hard no
fitting curves isn't that hard in one
dimension but what about 20 40 50 200 mm
dimensions or it gets harder then again
we have all these tools now for flexible
inference that didn't exist or couldn't
really be implemented well 20 years ago
and say propensity scores were being
developed now we've got them so if
you've heard about propensity scores
that's it's all about this it doesn't
solve your I haven't measured all the
confounders problem great tool and a lot
of ways in particularly because it lets
you see where you don't have overlap but
it's only solving this problem it's not
solving the hard problem okay
likewise all the other methods I'll be
talking about today are in that same
realm okay so there's been an explosion
of methods the vast majority of
literature in causal inference and
statistics in the past 20-30 years has
been about solving that problem believe
it or not
so all those matching methods weighting
methods sub classification that's all
about that
more recently acting in the past ten
years there have been more semi and
nonparametric methods moving on to kind
of combinations of all of these things
and ensemble methods say like the super
Lerner which I'll talk about a little
later okay
so before I get there again the
competition part of what we were
thinking about was okay there's a whole
literature there's a million methods out
there there's a whole literature why is
it so hard to figure out what to use or
how does the typical researcher decide
okay from my problem what usually you
know what it's about your field and the
journal you'd like to submit to you and
what they want to see which is a pretty
crappy way of deciding right so what
about science how should we be thinking
about how methods get developed and how
we evaluate them fairly so we wanted to
create a level testing ground so this is
what we saw in the literature most
papers only compare a few methods
methods where each there's no difference
between methods no one's showing you
that right because no comparisons are
Anathem up and there's a bias towards
shockingly given the incentives in
academia and beyond there's a bias
towards your own method like I want to
show simulations that make my method
look good right and if I kind of
inexpertly
you know implement the competition
method oh well it's not my method how
was I to know that I didn't choose the
tuning parameters correctly or I really
didn't do it justice and I'm not saying
anyone's being Machiavellian some people
maybe even recommend most people are not
being Machiavellian about it but there's
the incentives to do it right and to be
really fair and to actually move towards
the truth are not really there oh
there's a type of choice and you also
might only choose evaluation methods
that metrics that favor your method
right again are you thinking it's
through that way or you being doing that
explicitly or not it's it doesn't
s'matter right and then calibration to
real-life so because of this challenge I
said before but you know there's no real
data set where we know the truth there
are some things constructed
observational studies that lean in that
direction but in general that that
doesn't exist we often are simulating
how do we create simulations that look
like real-life in real data that's
really hard to do and I'm not saying we
you know change the world on that but we
tried to stick in that direction ok how
did we do it we crowdsource submissions
right we have that's what a competition
does send me your best math that you
implement it you think this is a great
method you tell me how to implement it
right or you implement it yourself we
had two different versions we're
reporting everything and we're putting
all the data out there and all the code
so that anyone can go back and use it
and try out and see fair comparisons we
really tried to incorporate a number of
metrics that would evaluate the
strengths and weaknesses of different
methods and we started at least with
covariant data from a real study in an
effort to try to calibrate towards real
life so the covariant derivative mminton
outcomes so that we would be able to
learn about you know for this kind of
the idea in our heads was if we have
this kind of assignment mechanism maybe
this kind of method does well or if our
response surface looks like this maybe
this kind of method it turns out we did
not learn that it was hard okay so
timeline boring about 15 do it yourself
I'll talk about those differences in a
second
submissions in about 15 black box
submissions okay we assume ignore
ability throughout what does that mean
it means we assumed throughout that you
had the researcher had all the
covariance they needed to do causal
inference so we got rid of that the hard
problem okay there's no confounding if
you control for the right set of
covariance which is a subset of the
covariance we hand you calibrated to in
real life I just talked about that we
simulated treatment assignments so we
knew
what the mechanisms were the goal is to
estimate the sample average tree oh
that's not right
say it's that sample average effect of
the treatment on the treated sorry that
should say sacked I'm going to talk
about the simulation knobs in a second
and we had two versions do it yourself
in the black box here are the simulation
knobs degree of non-linearity so I
showed you a picture or something
nonlinear before now we've got
non-linearity and roughly you know
somewhere between 10 and 50 dimensional
space depending on the setup we did that
in any of a variety of different ways
step functions exponentiating things etc
etc percent of treated where sometimes
some methods don't do well when there
aren't more controls and treated so we
varied that it was either 1/3 2/3 or the
opposite overlap balance that's was
another feature I showed you in the plot
before if you don't have a lot of
observations that overlap with each
other it gets harder alignment that has
to do with the fact that maybe you have
50 covariance and maybe 15 of them
predict the treatment and 20 of them
predict the response but only 5 predict
both in that case only 5 or confounders
and methods vary a lot in how good they
are at figuring that out and if you work
really hard to for instance if your
propensity score matching to balance all
the things that predict the treatment
that's not necessarily the best thing
for your treatment effect estimations
you may be ignoring important coverage
for the outcome and treatment effect
heterogeneity I think we had one setting
where everyone had the same treatment
effect and beyond that it was like the
picture where there's a lot of
heterogeneity ok then two different
competitions one with 7700 datasets we
have 77 settings that varied levels of
that knob each setting had a hundred
different manifestations then people
sent us methods that had to take a
certain kind
input and output something very specific
and boom we went to town with that the
other version was we handed out 20
datasets for people who really believe
this is an art form I need to do it
myself I need to be intimate with the
data and thinking about it etc we gave 2
out 20 datasets to do that
so I'm gonna focus less on that part of
the competition because it's harder to
make any strong conclusions with 20
datasets okay so here's a brief summary
of the winners we we did give out gold
medals they were gold covered plastic
medals really but but people I think
felt good about the medals that they got
so but in some times we didn't really
feel comfortable at the end of the day
saying that there were you know real
winners because they all kind of some
things that were good at this weren't
good at that etc but overall if you
really pushed us the winners were ones
that flexibly modelled the response
surface right which is new this has not
been emphasized in causal and prints in
the past thirty years everything has
been about modeling the treatment
assignment things like the propensity
score in part because again there
weren't these fancy methods until
recently that could do the other part
well so ones that really focused on the
expectation of the outcome conditional
on treatment and the covariance were the
ones that kicked ass at the end of the
day and those could have used a variety
of things to do that that flexible model
fitting from Bart random forests
Gaussian processes and often ensembles
thereof okay because at the end of the
day we were having a hard time learning
about what actually is the feature that
makes a difference and we couldn't
really learn that from our evaluation we
it was very noisy it was really hard to
find settings where one method really
dominated over the others we instead
created a bunch of new methods so it was
like you know
I think there was a toys heaven I was
little like transformers you could like
take the one piece of this and shove it
into that right you could like make cool
hybrids so it was it was a fun
experiment like that let's take this and
shove it over here and so I'll show you
a little about those as well
and we learned the most from that
process and it also made me think isn't
that a better way to do science where
instead of me saying for instance like I
I've written about Bart so Bart has to
win it's like well what if I take the
piece of Bart that's good and take the
cool thing about super learning that's
good and mash them together okay so here
are the people who run metals the first
is called count cause it's an ensemble
algorithm that uses cross-validation to
choose between random forests and
Gaussian processes I will say though
that it shows random forests 95% of the
time I'm working on Gaussian processes
and causal and prints right now and it's
has a lot of promise but it's hard to do
well automatically
Bart is Bayesian additive regression
trees the mean function of Bart is a sum
of week learning regression trees and it
avoids overfitting by default prior
distributions kind of like a Bayesian
form of boosted regression trees super
learner plus team Ellie's like the mark
vanderlin camp for people who know that
world so they had a big in somnolent
ensemble that had a wide actually it
wasn't that wide a library of different
options both to fit the response surface
and the assignment mechanism and then it
applied a target maximum likelihood
estimation adjustment at the end h2o by
the way all these things these are all
sitting in our and I'm gonna give you
links later or names of packages this is
another ensemble ensembles you not
surprisingly ensembles get to choose the
best along or a variety of methods so
the ensembles did really well except for
on computational time right so it also
chose from among a variety of options
oh wow I'm running out of time I will
say that in the do-it-yourself
competition there was one real standout
submission by jr. Lockwood which I don't
have time to talk about this is also all
in the paper that I'll give you is it
sitting on archive okay bunch of
different things we looked at so I'm
gonna actually skip I'm sorry the do it
yourself because it's 20 datasets and
it's sitting in the paper so it's all
out there instead I'm gonna show you the
7700 datasets so all the dark points so
we've got sorry bias our circles and our
MSC and and and left hand access our MSC
triangles and right hand axes but in
some sense and the the everything has
been standardized by the standard
deviation of the outcomes if you're used
to thinking like effect size
standardization it's it's like that
so one takeaway is that everything to
decently well or most things did
decently well if you think of like 0.05
as being kind of a reasonably small
level of bias the mashups do better
because what you know we took a bunch of
the good features and put them together
for the most part here are the winners
and then there are a bunch of other
methods that did fine just not
superlative okay so we actually didn't
learn a lot from that piece we learned
more from this and I apologize for this
because there's no way I'm just gonna
have to tell you what all these letters
mean but this is interval length versus
coverage so basically we want things
that cover so what things over here what
do you see there's nothing and we want
things up here because we want short
intervals so short intervals that cover
is the name of the game and we don't
have a lot of that so Bart did really
well with regard to our amazeen bias but
not with coverage with coverage it's
getting like 83% 82% it's got a really
short interval that's all though when
you switch it to have symmetric
intervals which makes no sense from a
Bayesian point of view it does much
better so we're still investigating that
when you add the propensity score as a
covariant it does much better when you
combine it with TM le does great alright
super learner similarly see that one
over there didn't do so great coverage
wise in the beginning when they added
Bert boom it did much better actually
that that was the super learner team who
went back and thought well let's throw
Bart in the library and they did and
they resubmitted so we're still learning
about the coverage but that was
interesting I have zero time and dinner
rather lunch is waiting so I'm gonna
skip this piece and just go to lessons
learned all right so the big the big
takeaways for us were that non-linear
response service is not the model for
the treatment but the model for the
response was really where the action was
which frankly fits with a lot of theory
barton random forests they've generally
liked read algorithms were the ones that
stood out as standalone as in non
ensemble algorithms coverage was a
problem across the board so we need to
think about that team Ellie I have to
say I was pretty cynical about it before
the competition and now I'm kind of sold
I still don't really understand it
because it's super hard but I'm working
more towards doing that and and have
built packages now that include it by
default because it's so helpful and I
will yes there's a new competition this
year which the deadline is April 30th
and it's a little tricky so but if you
goo well there's the link but also if
you just Google a CIC which stands for
Atlanta causal inference conference 2018
you will and challenge you'll get there
so I want to thank you for for attending
to this when you can smell the pizza in
the background and I'll just leave this
to show you the packages that are
sitting on cream
to highlight a new Bart causal one that
we're about to put on crayon I know I
said the same thing a month ago but that
incorporates a lot of the features a lot
of the good things we've learned from
this are now sitting in there but it's
ending on github if you want to help us
test it out the competition beta is
sitting on github so if you're writing a
causal inference paper and you need
testing grounds boom you've got seventy
seven hundred datasets across a wide
variety of settings use them and then
cite us of course and the paper is a
second round of reviews at steps i but
is sitting on archive so we'd love
comments on it so thank you very much
[Applause]
you